المتصل دعا الرئيس الاسرائيلي الى وقف
التعديلات القضائيه حفاظا على وحده
الاسرائيلي وبينما اعلن رئيس نقابه العمال
العامه الاضراب العام في المرافق
الاقتصاديه في اسرائيل فيما اعلنت لجنه
عمال مطار بن غوريون توقف حركه اقلاع
الطائرات بدورها اعلنت نقابه الاطباء
الاضراب العام في المرافق الصحيه حتى
تضاحي مسار التعديلات القضائيه في اسرائيل
كما اعلنت الجامعات الاسرائيليه شن اضراب
عام احتجاجا على التغييرات في الجهاز
القضائي واعلن رؤساء السلطات محليه عن
الدخول في اضراب المفتوح عن الطعام امام
ديوان رئاسه الوزراء في القدس الغربيه
اعتبارا من اليوم وسط هذه التطورات فقدت
العمله الاسرائيليه شيكل قيمتها في
التداولات
للمزيد معنا من امام الكنيست في القدس
مراسل الجزيره الياسكا نرحب بك الياس
ونبدا بهذا الخطاب
هو اسباب وتفسير تاجيل هذا الخطاب
[موسيقى]
حركه شاص للمتدينين الشرقيين وايضا حركه
يدوتها ترى للمتدينين الغربيين تقول هاتان
الحركتان نحن مع اي قرار يتخذه بين يمين
نتنياهو فيما يخص هذه التشريعات القضائيه
ايضا زعيم الصهيونيه الدينيه
يقول بان الحزب يعتبر وقف هذه التشريعات
عمليا خضوعا واستسلاما للفوضويين الذين
يقومون بالتظاهر ولكن من ناحيه اخرى
البيان الذي اصدره الحزب لا يحمل اي تهديد
في تفكيك التوليفه الحاكمه وفي زعزعه
اركان الحكومه على الاقل من جانب سموتريتش
وبالتالي تبقى الحلقه الاضعف الان بالنسبه
لبنيامين نتنياهو هي حلقه اتمار بن جير
الذي كما يبدو يهدد بزعزعه اركان الحكومه
وعمليا ما يمكن ان يقود الى انهيار
التوليفه الحاكمه من جانب اخر هنالك
لافت من جانب زعيمي حزب اسرائيل بيتنا
فيكتور ليبرمان وهو كان في اكثر من حكومه
وزيرا في حكومات بنيامين نتنياهو السابقه
وهو الان قبل حوالي ساعه يدعو اعضاء حزب
الكود عمليا الى الانقلاب على زعيم الحزب
بنيامين نتنياهو على رئيس الحكومه ويدعو
اعضاء الليكود الى تنحيه بنيامين نتنياهو
وتسميه شخص اخر من داخل اللكود ليراس
الحكومه وهذا ما من شانه ان اذا تم وهذا
طبعا سيناريو وارد لا احد يستطيع ان يتوقع
عكس ذلك وان يقول بان هذا السيناريو غير
ممكن لكن هذا ممكن بالفعل ان ينقلب اعضاء
في الليكود على بنيامين نتنياهو ويطلبون
تنحيته وبالتالي المضيف تشكيل توليفه
جديده في اسرائيل تنحي المتطرفين من اقصى
اليمين جانبا تخرج الاحزاب الدينيه خارج
هذه التوليفه وتضم في طياتها حزب اللكود
الحاكم المعارضه حزب يوجد مستقبل والمعسكر
الصهيوني
اسرائيل بيتنا وربما ايضا حزب العمل
وبالتالي توليفه يمينيه وايضا تضم احزاب
من يمين الوسط تكون قويه وقادره على
اجتياز هذه الازمه وهذه المرحله هذا
السيناريو من السيناريوهات الواضحه لكن
دعني اقول بان حكومه اليمين المتطرف واقصى
اليمين لا تتعجل لا تتعجل في اسقاط هذه
الحكومه التي خاضت من اجلها خمس انتخابات
متتاليه حتى غفرت بالسلطه وبالتالي
التوقعات بان يرضخ الجميع الى موقف
بنيامين نتنياهو الذي يبدو انه يقوده
باتجاه وقف هذه
التشريعات القضائيه على الاقل الى مرحله
الدوره الصيفيه بعد الاعياد اليهوديه وبعد
عيد الفصحى اليهودي والاعداد الوطنيه كما
تسمى في شهر نيسان ابريل المقبل اذا نحن
امام دقائق وساعات ربما حاسمه في هذا
السياق
الدقائق وساعات ودقائق حاسمه وهناك انقسام
كبير تداعيات حتى اقتصاديه وليست سياسيه
فقط انقسام بين من يتشبث بهذه التعبيرات
القضائيه ومن يعارضها بشده ولعلها تكون
فرصه
لتذكر او تعلم من لا يعلم بطبيعه هذه
التعديلات القضائيه ما هي طبيعتها ولماذا
هذا الانقسام حولها لهذه الى هذه الدرجه
نعم دعنا نقول بدايه بان الشرطه
الاسرائيليه فرضت هنا تقريبا طوقا شاملا
على مبنى الكنيست الاسرائيلي اغلقت معظم
الطرق المحيطه بالمبنى وهي تدفع بقوات
شرطيه وقوات خاصه هنالك خشيه بان تكون
هنالك صدامات ما بين الشرطه والمتظاهرين
الذين سوف يصلوا في الساعات القليله
المقبله الى مبنى الكنيست للاحتجاج وهنالك
ايضا دعوات من جانب اليمين الاسرائيلي
المتطرف الى المجيء الى هنا والى مواقع
اخرى وبالتالي التوقعات لصدامات بين
المعسكرين المؤيد والمعارض من الواضح بان
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تعتبر هذه التعديلات
القضائيه بانها اصلاحات على جهاز القضاء
اما المعارضه فهي تقول بان هذا التفاف على
سلطه القانون وهي انقلاب على النظام الحكم
في اسرائيل وانقلاب على الديمقراطيه خذ
على سبيل المثال ما تم هذا اليوم مناقشته
في لجنه الدستور والقضاء البرلمانيه وايضا
التصديق عليه لتحضيره للقراءتين والثالثه
في الكنيست ليصبح قانونا نافذا وهو مساله
تغيير وتعديل لجنه تعيين القضاه في
اسرائيل بحيث تكون الغلبه والاغلبيه من
بين اعضائها هي لصالح الائتلاف الحاكم سته
اعضاء مقابل ثلاثه قضاه واثنين من
المعارضه
الاسرائيليه هذا يعني من وجهه نظر
المعارضه بان الحكومه هي التي تتحكم في من
سيكون من هم القضاه في اسرائيل بمعنى ان
القضاه ربما يصبحون موظفين لدى الحكومه
وهذا بالتالي يتنافى مع اهم اسس
الديمقراطيه والفصل بين السلطات وهذا واحد
من كثير من التعديلات التي تحاول الحكومه
الاسرائيليه من خلالها اضعاف سلطه المحكمه
العليا واضعاف سلطه انفاذ القانون وواضح
بان بنيامين نتنياهو المتشبث بالسلطه بسبب
ما يلاحقه من تهم فساد هو المعني الاول
والاخير في هذه التعديلات القضائيه التي
تخدم مصالحه في قادم الايام هنالك عده
قوانين تسعى هذه الحكومه تمريرها في اطار
هذه التشريعات هذا التشريع الذي تحدثت عنه
لجنه القضاه هو ربما الاساسي والجوهري لكن
ايضا تقييد المحكمه العليا من التدخل في
قرارات سياسيه وتعينات سياسيه للحكومه
ومنع هاء المحكمه العليا من ابطال قوانين
يشرعها الكنيسه الاسرائيلي عاده ما كانت
تلجا المحكمه الى هذا الاجراء على اعتبار
ان الحكومه كانت تقر مشاريع قوانين غير
دستوريه ومنافيه للقوانين الاساسيه ولحقوق
الانسان ولحقوق الفرد ولحقوق الاقليه
وكانت المحكمه بمثابه المدافع عن هذه
الاقليات وبالتالي عندما تمنع المحكمه
العليا من هذه الوسيله وبالتالي فان
الحكومه تتحول الى ديكتاتوريه والى صاحبه
الكلمه الاخيره كما تقول المعارضه في هذا
الشان وفي شؤون اخرى بطبيعته قبل حاله
الجدل والسجالات الان واضح هذا الائتلاف
الحاكم الى اي مد هو على المحك سيناريو
على سبيل المثال انهيار هذا التحالف هل هو
سيناريو الاقرب للتحقق الان
لا لا نستطيع ان نؤكد ذلك لان هذا يتعلق
بيد قاده الاحزاب الاسرائيليه وقلت بان
هنالك تفكك وتفاوت في وجهات النظر في داخل
حزب اللكودنا لكمن يريد ان يوقف هذه
التغييرات القضائيه هناك من يعارض ذلك لكن
ربما تكون لبنيامين نتنياهو السلطه على
حزبه لكن ليست لديه السلطه ربما على
شركائه في الائتلاء هو استطاع ان يحتوي
كما يبدو الاحزاب الدينيه التي قالت بانها
سوف تؤيد اي قرار ياخذه بمعنى اذا اعلن
وقف التغييرات
القضائيه هم سيدعمون ذلك وان قال عكس ذلك
فهم معه ايضا احزاب اقصى اليمين سموت على
الاقل لم يهدد بتفكيكي وزعزعه اركان
الحكومه يبقى الان على المحك موقف لتمر
وزير الامن القومي وموقفه من هذا الموضوع
انا اعتقد على الاقل في الوقت الراهن
اعضاء الائتلاف هذه الحكومه اليمنيه
المتطرفه لن تتعجل ان تفكك نفسها بنفسها
وان تقضي على استمرار هذه الحكومه بمواصله
الحكم في اسرائيل
وبالتالي نتوقع ان يتراجع الجميع
وربما يلتفوا حول بنيامين في القرار الذي
سوف ياخذه في نهايه المطاف على الاقل في
هذه المرحله لكن واضح بان
وقف هذه التشريعات هي بدايه لزعزعه
استقرار هذه التوليفه الحاكمه في اسرائيل
وتحديدا من جانب احزاب اليمين المتطرف
التي يبدو انها غير راضيه ولم تكن تتوقع
بان هذه الحكومه سوف تكون سابقتها في كثير
من الامور في تعاطيها مثلا مع الملف
الفلسطيني وغيرها من الملفات وبالتالي هذه
القضيه اليوم ان اوقفت اوقفت هذه
التغييرات القضائيه ربما تكون حاسمه
وقاسمه في تحديد وجهه هذه الاحزاب في قادم
الايام وقادم الشهور شكرا جزيلا لك من
امام الكنيسه في القدس مراسله الجزيره
الياسكارا